thank you for staying with us here at 4
30 I'm Kirsten join and I'm Brian Loftis
testing and treatment for HIV was
stalled during the pandemic and now
another obstacle could limit that
progress even further a Texas judge
judge part of the Affordable Care Act
last month it requires most insurance to
provide an HIV prevention drug for free
and as 8 news now reporter Ryan Matthey
shows us the ruling could go far beyond
just HIV
[Music]
a 33 year old Akeem Rollins found his
queer community at just 15 then began
exploring what kind of sex do I like
what kind of sex don't I like then
during a routine visit with his doctor
she asked why aren't you on prep and I
said
I I don't know I don't really know that
much about it this is prep or
pre-exposure prophylaxis a once a day
pill that the CDC says reduces the risk
of getting HIV dramatically through sex
or injection drug use the Southern
Nevada Health District reports over 4
300 users in Clark County alone when I
gauge sexually with another person
there's something not here anymore and
that thing that left was anxiety or fear
that was always there afterwards we're
at a place where we can end the HIV
epidemic but this is going to stop that
progress now a recent ruling in Texas
could restrict access Nationwide the
Affordable Care Act currently requires
most insurance plans to cover the
prescription along with other
preventative Services not related to HIV
a federal judge in March struck down
this provision of the ACT arguing the
task force who chooses which
preventative Services are eligible for
coverage was not appointed by the Senate
and unlawful it means that if you were
going in for your mammogram you would
suddenly have to pay for that instead if
you want your HIV or STI screening you'd
need to pay for that instead of being
able to get that for free that reduces
access for people and it comes as Clark
County begins to see Rising HIV
diagnoses in all genders that it hasn't
seen since before the pandemic
pharmacist said it was three thousand
dollars for me to get prep a biomedical
HIV prevention Summit at the cosmo Hotel
this week emphasizing the need for this
drug Beyond just the queer Community we
are all HIV possible you know so we are
all susceptible and potentially
vulnerable to HIV
the Biden Administration is currently
appealing a Texas judge's decision
meanwhile our state does rank fifth in
the nation in terms of positive HIV
cases for the time being prep and these
other preventative Services are still at
no cost under most insurance plans